red fire ants like these in the American
South have gotten a bad rap in our world
most people know them has those pesky
critters with a sting that burns like
crazy but fire ants embody some of our
society's most cherished ideals first of
all they are incredibly strong able to
carry ten times their body weight can
you imagine your average adult male
lifting a one-ton truck huh and let's
talk teamwork you wouldn't think a fire
ant could bring down this giant
dragonfly and it couldn't but a whole
bunch of fire ants can in fact when it's
on the ground the dragonfly looks like
it's drowning and fire ants teamwork
also helps fire ants reproduce these
worker ants act as well ground crew
urging this virgin would be queen
skyward so she can mate
some 200 feet in the air after mating
the queen will produce up to 200 eggs an
hour three million daughters over the
course of her life
I say daughters because all the worker
ants are females the Queen only produces
males in the spring and only for the
purpose of mating what a life huh guys
yeah let's get back to teamwork these
strong motivated well organized insects
have an amazing ability to work together
for a common goal in this case the
overnight consumption of a frog carcass
I asked everyone who works in an office
come on
could your company organize and execute
something this complex on the spur of
the moment fire ants if you want a
strong productive role model it's into
teamwork
look no further